right now lawmakers have just an hour to
complete their legislative session for
months of work coming down to that last
deadline
a news now is your only local station on
the ground in carson city
the i-team's david charns was there on
day one joins us live with
the rush to finish hi there david
hey there brian it's a long day 120 and
they've got about 55 minutes to end this
legislative session it has to be
finished by midnight
right now they've passed those marijuana
lounges that a lot of folks were looking
for there are some stipulations with
that that will be regulated
they also passed that public health
insurance option that would be run by
the state but i want to talk about
some changes to the election process
that you'll see in the next couple of
years lawmakers passing how we will vote
first nevada will switch from caucuses
to primaries the next primary
that's when we political parties choose
their presidential candidate that would
happen in february 2024
and the way we voted in the last
election will become the law of the land
with the governor's signature
that means you can still vote in person
but you would opt
out rather than opt-in of getting a
mail-in ballot
we believe that as a as a constitutional
right people should have
every option to fully participate and
there are others that think it's more of
a privilege well
it's a constitutional right we were so
used to in nevada to getting our
election results
at midnight because everything was done
electronic they did it so well
now you allow mail-in ballots to come in
a little later and so it's
days almost a week until you get your
election results
and people automatically start to begin
to get suspicious
the other big headline here today mining
companies will face a new excise tax
designed to bring in money to fund
nevada schools it was either face
possibly even higher taxes if this was
brought out to voters
this plan based past that is with
democrats and republican support
and it's expected to bring in millions
of dollars for education
a pretty i think unique and historic
presentation
of legislation here in this building
with the speaker our mining industry
sitting at the table
willing to support education here in the
state which we are very grateful for
mining had a gun to their heads don't
kid yourself so i don't really even have
a problem with mining pay a reasonable
additional amount but they've got to be
exceptionally careful mining has a
reputation especially
in clark county where it's like this
super wealthy
organization that doesn't pay any taxes
and that's just nonsense
now the other big item that passed today
is that right to work bill
which allows people who lost their jobs
in the tourism industry to
get their jobs back you'd have to have
that job for more than six months of
course be laid off during the pandemic
the culinary union estimates 98 percent
of strip workers
lost their jobs during the pandemic 50
percent are back and
this they say will bring people back to
work so we got about 55 minutes
never know what's going to happen but
we'll keep you posted here on 8 news now
at 8newsnow.com
live in carson city i'm david charns 8
news now